Yes time to lose a few more loved ones
as today we are diving back into Jujutsu
Kaisens culling game and let me just say,
This isn't just any old colony aswell,
we are FINALLY back with the gambling
mad man himself Hakari in Tokyo Colony 2.
So to start things off here we are actually
throwing away any idea of that culling game
and going back to before the country wide idle
transfiguration where a young man with blue hair
and blue eyes named Charles Bernard filled
out his visitor's registration at Shueisha's
publishing house in Tokyo. Two of the staff
members noticed and discussed if he brought
in a manga submission also commenting on
how unusual it is for a Gaijin to do so.
Charles later ends up meeting a Shueisha staff
member to review his manga submission. While
improperly sitting on a desk, Charles expressed
that he's always pondered what makes a manga
creator. They don't need licenses and
in Charles' opinion, experience doesn't
necessarily validate a creation either. (Which
makes sense, like Isayama for example had never
made a manga before attack on Titan ANYYYWAYYYS)
The employee looked over Bernard's manga while
hardly listening to his words, wishing he would
just sit in a chair. He only commented that the
foreigner's Japanese is pretty good but Charles
responded by repeating the same sentiment back,
confusing the man. (Hate cutting myself off
this much, BUT if you guys watch anyone who
lives in Japanese and is a foreigner this is
a pretty common thing to hear to the point its
almost an underhand insult) The employee
stated that's obviously the case because
he's Japanese and Charles reveals that he was
born and raised in Japan although his parents
are French. The employee apologized for assuming
and Charles dismissed it because he believed it
would be the start of a long relationship
between him and the publishing studio.
YET, This DOG of a Shueisha employee
is mostly unimpressed by Charles' manga
submission and critiques the story,
the genre, the tone, and most of all,
the artwork. He used one example of one panel
where a character's finger is bent too much in
one direction. The employee tries to show Charles
by pointing his own finger in demonstration,
but Charles immediately breaks it
to match the manga's art. Irritated,
Charles told the man to watch movies or stare at
photos if he wanted realistic artwork. He believed
a publishing house should appreciate the passion
that can't be replicated in precise artwork.
Charles finishes his tirade after assaulting
the employee and storms out of the building,
deeming the entire experience a waste of
time. SO YEAH DUNNO WHAT THAT WAS ABOUT!
probably just a small warning from Gege to
any future publishers about his artwork haha
Skipping forward now though to the fateful day
of November the 12th we find that somehow this
pure manga reading degenerate Charles is outside
and on a ferries wheel with Kinji Hakari inside
of the culling game. He asks Hakari if he
knows exactly what makes someone a manga
creator, yet as we could probably imagine, an
annoyed, Hakari answers that he doesn't care.
Just lacking, Charles is thankful there is still
electricity powering the area but Hakari isn't
and suggests he normally wouldn't ride a Ferris
wheel with another man. Charles points out that he
could've refused but Hakari wants to scope out the
area in case he brings a girl back one day, cause
ya know big brain thinking n all pre planning for
future events as the man knows the culling game
aint gonna merc him. Charles is surprised Hakari
believes Tokyo will recover from the Culling Game,
claiming that he is the exact opposite, as someone
who's only come to gaze upon the end of it all.
Ever since curses flooded Tokyo, there haven't
been outlets for manga, and creators that
Charles respected are giving up. Charles asks
Hakari to give him a reason to fight because
the heroes in battle manga's are always fighting
for positive reasons while the Culling Game only
incites fights for negative ones. Charles asks
Hakari to provoke him enough to instill hatred
inside of him the point where he could take
him out without remorse. Hearing this, Hakari
decides to oblige and thoroughly insults Charles.
He says he would never read Charles' creepy manga
because his gloomy disposition might infect him.
Then in probably the best line of the entire damn
manga so far, he also tells Charles to stop
whining and to start fighting, YOU CREEPY
OTAKU. INSULTED AND with tears in his eyes,
Charles asks why he’d say such a mean thing?
Ready to fight Hakari for his rude comments,
Charles conjures the G Warstaff, a pen-shaped
spear. Immediately he attacks, bursting through
their pod and forcing Hakari outside on top of the
ferris wheel where his assault continues.
Charles thrusts his spear at Hakari's head
several times while quoting a "poem" from a
creator he admires. Hakari simply avoids the
strikes and jumps off the ferris wheel onto a
building below, causing the Frenchman to chase
after. Standing there its shown that or special
grade demon is a lil annoyed because Charles is
actually quoting a comment from Katsura Hoshino,
which Hakari just doesn't consider a poem.
Charles expands upon the "poem" by explaining
that a mangaka enters a fictitious space in
their minds where anything is possible because to
them reality just isn't satisfying. He continues
stating he believes his reality has been overtaken
by jujutsu and because of this he has lost his
motivation as both a manga reader and creator. He
asks Hakari what that feeling is called and the
suspended student replies with that he’s getting
bored. As his fighting spirit begins rising,
Charles suggests that the feeling
he’s got is called despair instead.
Fueled by sorrow for his opponent, Charles
strikes hard with his G Warstaff and scratches
Hakari's cheek open, drawing a bit of blood at
the pen's tip. Noticing that the spear is a pen,
Hakari asks him if it's okay for a mangaka
to use their drawing pen for violence,
but Charles argues using a reference from
Captain Tsubasa. Following this he activates
the condition for his cursed technique
and marks Hakari with a glowing square.
Curiously confused Hakari asks what's going on
as he throws a flying kick but Charles is able
to avoid it and immediately counterattacks with
an attack surprising the former. Easily though,
Hakari maintains his balance as he's knocked
back several meters from the blow, although he
personally didnt take any damage, his sleeve was
cut open. While examining the tear, Hakari also
analyzes the way the Frenchman moved and decides
that it has to be more than a simple reflex.
Noticing that the Special Grade Sorcerer
took his hands out of his pockets,
Charles taunts him for it and then
explains that the glowing square is
actually a manga panel that lets the user
see their opponent's next move. Currently,
the Frenchman can only see one second in advance
but as the pen tip fills with Hakari's blood,
the former will be able to see further into
the future. Having heard this, Hakari dashes
straight at Charles to confirm this abilities
effect and nearly lands a powerful right hook,
with the latter admitting it would've taken
him out if not for the effect of G Warstaff.
Quickly after Charles counters his attack and
hits Hakari across the head with the blunt
end of his spear, affirming to him that
the Frenchman really can see the future!
However, Hakari is unimpressed by the dudes
ability and disappears from Charles' line of
sight, before he re appears and punches Charles
in the back, stating that he still needs to be
able to see him in order to see the future
through his technique. To counter, Hakari
attacks Charles repeatedly from his blindspots
without letting up. In an attempt to retaliate,
Charles tries to stab Hakari in the back but the
latter has already anticipated he would try that
and intercepts before striking him again.
Before Charles can turn around and recover,
Hakari completely and utterly blitzes him while
stating that he can't just go easy on him because
he knows Charles would just selfishly attack
someone else later. Continuing Hakari believes
that in to stop this he needs to utterly break
Charles and hits him with an extremely powerful
punch. Then he quickly goes to get behind him
again, but Charles is able to recover from the
previous punch in time and reactively strikes his
blindspot, slightly cutting Hakari's forehead.
Irate over how the battles going, Charles claims
that the vessel containing his heart is broken
and is now spilling out in a gush of emotion. He
adds that now due to gaining more ink in his pen,
he can see two seconds into Hakari's future and
will be waiting in his blind spot. Confused as
to why Hakari isn't intimidated, Charles
asks his opponent why he's just standing
there posing while in this situation. I don't
think Charles has bumped into anyone who can
create a domain expansion and due to this
while Hakari stands there he uses both his
hands to form the proper hand sign to cast
his domain expansion, Idle Death Gamble. Due
to his domain's guaranteed effect, its rules
are instantly transmitted to Charles' brain.
(ronin) Instantly the Frenchy begins to understand
the rules of Hakari’s Domain Expansion. It shown
that ‘idle death gamble’ is based on a Japanese
pachinko machine inspired by the shoujo series CR
Private Pure Love Train. During the domains active
phase, the user must hit the jackpot by getting
three of the same symbol, which will allow them to
get a bonus. There's a flow of 3 different levels
that determines the percentage of increased
probability and also the probability of the
jackpot through a visual effect, which Hakari can
choose, though ultimately this all depends on the
so called luck Hakari refers to. Also certain
riichi scenarios can be activated at points
throughout this process, and chance boosters
allow for increase in the chance of a jackpot.
Having heard all this Charles yells out
annoyed by the sudden info dump that was
literally just implanted in his brain, as the
first stage of Hakari’s domain begins. Quickly,
Kinji releases a green and red visual effect
attack, which Charles dodges out of the
way causing it to activate into a riichi
scenario, changing the scene around them.
(ronin) Its explained to the
confused Charles that if the
character "Yuki" passes through the gate,
then Hakari immediately hits the jackpot.
Charles attempts to swipe at it, but it's
just a visualization so nothing happens,
meaning all he can do is wait to see
the result. (Whiich is kinda sus,
its almost just a guaranteed jackpot whenever
a Riichi scenario pops up, I wonder if thats a
house rule type thing, referring back to how
his domain is based on a pachinko machine.
(ronin) Due to the indicator being
weak, the riichi scenario fails
causing them to restart back at the
beginning of the Domains expansion.
Standing there, Charles thinks about how
he can't use his manga cursed technique to
predict the outcome, meaning that the process
will repeat continuously until he defeats him,
or Kinji draws a winner, which he
knows would result in his loss for him.
However, to Kinji's surprise, what Charles
is most infuriated at is the presentation,
taking the beloved Private Pure Love Train
manga and turning it into something bizarre
for gambling. He continues to try and attack,
questioning how long he will keep this up
with the jackpot rate being only a 1/239,
however Kinji is still able to effortlessly
dodge each attack, while confidently
stating he's never gone past 30 times.
This time Hakari activates a riichi
scenario with an 80% success rate,
anxiously watching the outcome while the
two continue to duke it out. He's unable
to focus on Kinji's future attacks as he tries
to pay attention to the riichi, calling on the
"Yume" character to get on the train, in hopes
of preventing the jackpot. Sadly for him though
the train leaves, and "Yume" disappears,
allowing Charles to slice at Hakari’s side.
Charles explains while confidently standing there,
that if it was a game of skill rather than luck,
Hakari might have won, but as he turns around
he is shocked to find "Yume" is still standing
there saying she missed the train, meaning
he had indeed actually won the jackpot.
Quickly he darts in and kicks Charles away,
declaring he uses skill to grab ahold of luck.
(no-operator as Panda) Elsewhere in the Tokyo
No. 2 Colony, Panda sits alone atop a shipping
container in a shipyard. Upon smelling the air,
he notes tell that roughly three people have been
dismembered nearby. He also can hardly sense the
perpetrator's presence, which might suggest that
they can freely activate their curse energy.
Sitting there, Panda reviews the plan that he
and everyone had agreed on beforehand, which was
to find and negotiate with Hana Kurusu. They’d
planned to leave the fighting to
Hakari, but the barrier just like
over in Tokyo Colony No.1 with Yuji
and Megumi split them up upon entry,
to one of those random spawn locations.
Although Panda knows he must leave the area,
he notes that acting rashly will expose him to
the wrong person. After a bit more thinking, Panda
decides to take off and rolls his cute behind off
the shipping container to go in search of Hana.
(no-operator as Panda) Once he landed, he looks
both ways and sighs a breath of relief. However,
at that exact moment, Hajime Kashimo walks right
around the corner. In a split second reaction,
Panda "plays a real life panda" by standing
on all fours to avert suspicion, and initially
this works, with Hajime confusedly thinking that
a panda must've wandered out of the nearby Zoo.
However, Hajime has a omega sized brain
and summons his Kogane to asks if that
panda was a player, with the latter
pretty much instantly confirming it.
(no-operator as Panda) Witnessing this
happen infront of his teddy bear eyes,
Panda was surprised to learn
that they have that function.
Yet before Panda really even had time
to react, the Ancient GOD LEVEL SORCERER
Hajime had quickly charged at him and
delivered a powerful blow to his torso,
completely erupting a large portion
of the stuffing holding him together,
before following up this brutal attack
and electrocuting him. Then not done,
Hajime while insulting his strength hits him with
his staff and knocks Panda back into a container.
(no-operator as Panda) Having been
brutally beaten, Panda notes that
Hajime's cursed energy is similar to Megumi's
Nue where both have electrified cursed energy
surging through their bodies, making it utterly
unblockable. With his Panda form destroyed,
the puppeteer begins transforming into his Gorilla
Mode and strikes Hajime with the
prolific Unblockable Drumming Beat.
Noticing a change, Hajime takes a defensive
stance and endures the multitude of blows. He
says that the attack wasn't too bad, but it
was great either and follows up by using his
staff to tear off Panda's right arm. Then
continuing with his old-school brutality,
he throws Panda's own arm straight back
into his face, completely blinding the
defenseless bear allowing the Sneaky sorcerer to
approach from the puppets right. Darting in he
delivers a flurry of absolutely brutal hits
directly aimed at the Panda’s face, sending
him shooting back into another container. As the
broken sorcerer strolls up on the beaten puppet
he calls him pathetic and weak, before asking
if he knows the current whereabouts of Sukuna.
(no-operator as Panda) Taken by surprise by the
demonic lord statement on Sukuna, Panda doesn't
know why he's interested in him, but quickly
comes to the realization that he wouldn't
be a good matchup Yuji, so while trying to
think up an excuse he said he doesn't know.
Noticing the massive amount of
stalling before answering his question,
Hajime realizes he’s lying and demands that
he spit it out as he'll show mercy if he does.
(no-operator as Panda) Having thought up an
excuse now, even if it be a weak one, Panda
says that his uncle goes by the same name,
so hearing it took him off guard initially.
Hajime though who easily figures out
he’s still lying, doesn't appreciate
being looked down on by the cursed puppet
and tells him to stop ‘playing’ with him.
(no-operator as Panda) Annoyed now, Panda
retorts by saying he's the one being
looking down and tells him to be aware
of his sister as anyone who meets her eyes
she tries to kill out of pure embarrassment.
All of a sudden a massive horn is seen
from panda’s nose as his body begins
to transform and his head morphs into a giant
triceratops skull. However in that exact moment,
Hajime charges up his own attack and a lightning
bolt appears between them. Its explained that,
Kashimo separates the cursed energy’s charges
like electricity. When he strikes an opponent,
so all of the hits he landed on panda earlier,
it transfers a positive charge into the target.
Then when the negative charge that lays inside
of Kashimo is discharged, it launches directly
at the target without shooting off to any other
surface. This results in lightning that literally
cant miss, as it will travel directly to its
opponent pretty much taking away any need for
Kashimo to actually use a domain as this is kinda
a sure hit technique. Sadly as the transformation
is still happening, that said lightning bolt
strikes and decimate’s Panda mortally wounding
him. Standing above the fallen puppet, Hajime
once again asks Panda about Sukuna's whereabouts!
As we flow into a flashback we see young Panda
being beat up by his big brother Gorilla. The
young teddy screams for his sister's aid,
and an angry Triceratops marches over,
demanding that Gorilla cease his bullying. Yet
the young Gorilla trys saying that they were just
fighting like a dude from a game. Hearing that,
Triceratops says that Panda should get the next
turn to fight back, with Gorilla being completely
fine with it. Listening to his older siblings,
Panda looking hella cute rolls up to smack his
bro a few times, however he quickly gets punched
in the face by the latter, making him cry even
more. Completely blown away with what she just
witnessed, Triceratops runs off in hot pursuit
while Panda continues crying out behind them.
Later, Panda is seen holding a Santa Claus ball
while trying to follow his older brother and
his puppet friends. Not wanting him to follow,
cause they find the training wheels lame. The
fox whispers something into the raccoons ears
and he tells Panda that he can join under he
condition that he throws his ball into the river.
Initially Panda hesitates, claiming that it was
a gift from Santa, but after the two pressured
him and seeing his older brothers grumpy stare,
Panda tosses the ball into the river. Blown away
with him actually doing it, the raccoon and fox
tell him that throwing stuff into the river
is illegal, as it would harm the environment,
before they ran off aiming to tell the
police. Gorilla rudely asks a saddened
Panda why he did that, telling him that it was a
precious gift from Santa. Breaking down in tears,
Panda screams at him that he just
wanted to play with his big brother.
At night before bedtime, Triceratops
berates Gorilla for bullying Panda,
instead telling him that when other kids pick on
him, he has to be the one to stand up for him.
Gorilla counters this stating that she plays with
the other girls and wouldn't understand because
of this. He says that he can't have fun with
Panda around as he holds him back and he only
ever seems to start crying when she shows up.
Gorilla thinks that she's far to cushy on him,
but Triceratops views this differently. She
notes that no matter how mean Gorilla is to him,
Panda shrugs off all the bad things and cheers up
by the time its time to eat. He literally doesn't
have a bad bone in his body and believes
that thats how brothers should always be!
She belittles Gorilla by saying that maybe
he’s the spoiled one, as Panda always ends
up forgiving him for his transgressions.
Suddenly interrupting the two of them,
Panda storms into the room with a beetle and
shows it to Gorilla, who immediately points out
that its a Dorcus Titanus Stag Beetle and screams
while throwing it out of the window in horror.
Before going to bed, Gorilla open their piggy
bank to see if he has enough change to buy a
replacement ball for Panda. As he begins
trying to sleep, he just thinks that an
idiot like Panda would be fine with any ball.
Suddenly though in the middle of the night,
a voice tells him to wake up. Coming out of a
daze, he notices that both he and Triceratops
are being led by a strange ghost-man. (who’s
obviously some puppet version of Masamichi
fr) He quickly recognizes the figure as
their father and asks why they're going
and for how long. Their father answers that
there's no reason and that it's permanent.
At that moment, a terrified Panda burst out the
house, desperately searching for his big bro and
big sis. Gorilla screams back for panda and
tells his father to stop, however the ghostly
man just tells him thats enough. Gorilla cuts in
by saying that Panda can't survive without him,
since he’s literally terrible at everything
he does, and would get left behind because
he’s completely helpless by himself. Not
understand what's actually going on though,
The father tell him that they're the
ones being left behind and not Panda,
so be a good big brother and say goodbye. A
confused Gorilla gets defense, wondering about
how he was gonna buy the ball for him tomorrow
and that he needed him there to talk to the shop
keepers instead of their sister. But sadly, after
a second thought he finally catches on and fully
begins to break down in tears, not wanting
to leave this world and his brothers side.
Back in the real world... Hajime Kashimo stands
over the bloodied mess of Panda's obliterated
corpse. While prodding the bear, He notes that he
didn't gain any points from him before realizing
that he probably hasn't found the core of the
Panda yet. He picks up Panda's head with his
staff and asks once again about the whereabouts
of Sukuna. BUT Panda simple replies like the true
friend and legend he is that "Panda’s are very
tight lipped." Taking this as an insult, Hajime
threatens to fully destroy the rest of Panda.
Yet just as he raised his bloodlust to do so,
THE LEGEND HIMSELF, WITH HIS CURSE ENERGY ALREADY
FULLY FLAIRED UP AND WITH THE ANGER OF THE ENTIRE
JUJUTSU TECH ON HIS BACK, DROPS IN COMPETELY
DESTROYING A SHIPPING CONTAINER IN THE PROCESS.
INSTANTLY HE SCREAMS AT HIS BOY ASKING IF HE’S
LOST SOME WEIGHT! Seeing his classmate, Panda
is happy and shouts out Hakari’s name, while an
initially confused Hajime begins to get riled up!
Supercharged with an incredible volume of cursed
energy, Hakari rushes in to rescue Panda from
Kashimo. He delivers a right hook so powerful that
it disarms Kashimo and sends the sorcerer crashing
through several freight containers. AHHHH THIS
IS GOING TO BE PURE INSANITY BOOOOYS and girls of
course, INSTANTLY Hakari follows up, not giving
Kashimo any time to recover. Having closed the
distance, the special grade does a sick 2 footed
jump, throwing himself into the air and delivering
a flying dropkick his opponent’s face that Hajime
just narrowly avoids. While still in mid-air,
Hakari swings his legs straight back in an
attempt to land a hit, with his opponent just
barely grazing his nose. As Hajime stands there in
shock, Hakari’s physical power is so overwhelming
that his kick’s excess cursed energy dents another
shipping container and completely deforming it.
Standing opposite Hajime, Hakari is electrified
by the cursed energy protecting his opponent but
also barely feels the bad side effects from
it. Kashimo is impressed that his opponent
can ignore the electrification and asks his
name. Hakari introduces himself while Kashimo
is still just completely fascinated by the
insane cursed energy output and mysterious
music surrounding his opponent. Moving into his
fighting stance, Kashimo also introduces himself
and as Hakari hears his name he realizes that
this is the player with the one hundred points.
Knowing that he needs them, he cheekily asks
if he can use those points if he's victorious,
with Kashimo agreeing and asking to know
more about Sukuna if he's the victor.
Feeling it coming in, Hakari is suddenly and
orgasmicly distracted as a large influx of
cursed energy received as a bonus from hitting his
domain's jackpot envelopes him. Noting somethings
up, Kashimo uses the opportunity to barrage his
opponent with several hits but quickly becomes
displeased as Hakari isn't resisting. As he
begins to tell Hakari not to disappoint him,
the special grade sorcerer switches things up a
little and rattles the ancient sorcerer with an
abrupt right hook to the jaw that sends Kashimo
flying. After posing, literally playing the air
guitar to go along with his own damn theme
song, Hakari instantaneously disappears from
the spot he was in to follow up with a flying knee
to Hajime’s gut, prompting him to admit that his
opponent isn't bad at all. Landing back on his
feet, Hajime regains his balance, grabs onto
the leg Hakari kneed him with and counterattacks
with a spinning elbow straight to the chin of the
sorcerer. Overcoming it though, Hakari withstands
the attack and forces Kashimo to release his grip
by jumping down, completely smashing the ground
beneath their feet with a straight punch.
Jumping back out of Hakari’s range, Kashimo
who’s charged back up, discharges the same
lightning attack that defeated Panda. Being
able to see the approaching lightning,
Hakari is able to avoid a direct hit to his head
but sadly his arm is blown off by the attack.
Glad and Confident that his opponent won't
be able to recover in time after being hit,
Kashimo rushes in to finish him off. However,
Hakari is on his GON level of strength and
doesn't care about his arm at all. Instead he
surprisingly counters with a kick straight to
Hajime’s face and follows up with a punch
from the same arm that was supposedly just
severed. Blown away by seeing Hakari’s arm
re-appear Kashimo just manages to block the
attack and assumes Hakari used a reverse
cursed technique to quickly heal himself.
Its then explained, that when Hakari hit
the Jackpot with his Domain Expansion. It
resulted in a bonus of unlimited cursed energy
throughout the round. Hakari never learned to
use reverse cursed technique but the unlimited
cursed energy coursing through his body as a
result of hitting the jackpot automatically
heals his body with it. In other words,
Hakari is pretty much damn immortal four
minutes and eleven seconds after hitting the
jackpot, which is the duration of the Private
Pure Love Train theme song "Admiring You".
This time limit then comes to an end
and the ancient sorcerer notices the
random music surrounding Hakari has stopped,
causing his opponent's cursed energy to recede
to normal. However, during the previous round
and due to how Hakari's cursed technique works
after he hits a jackpot, his cursed energy and
technique is replenished, allowing him to cast
another domain expansion immediately. SOOOO for
as long as Hakari continues to hit the jackpot,
he can use his domain over and over and over
and over again. So yeah THIS IS THE REASON WHY
HAKARI IS BROKEN AND GOJO REASONS THAT HE COULD
SURPASS HIM SOMEDAY. MAN HAS LITERALLY FIGURED
OUT AN INFINITE CURSED ENERGY HACK LIKE ITS
JUST SOME GAME OF MAGIC OR SOMETHING OML.
So because of the fact that big
rari’s Domain Expansion is harmless,
he can be as aggressive as he wants
and his activation is extremely quick,
probably one of the quickest in the
entire universe, like it states here
that the dude’s activation is faster
than that of Mahito’s during shibuya.
As the rules of the Idle Death Gamble are sent
into Hajime's mind. He notes that since he's
aware that the game is a "probability-loop type",
it means he’s likely to keep hitting a jackpot
as he activates "Increased Probability".
Standing there Hakari asks him how he is,
but Hajime points out that during
this period he's not unkillable and
Kinji simply responds the that life
of gambling always comes with risks.
Flashing in, The two monstrous sorcerers trade
a flurry of brutal punches, before Kinji spins
away and activates his "continuation effect"
absolutely confusing Hajime with what's going on.
It then explained that currently, Hakari
is redoing one consecutive effect sequence.
The normal percentage chance of hitting
the jackpot is over 20% or 1 in 5 on its
first activation and because of that there
is usually a high risk of drawing a dud,
so typically he only uses this activation
when he has increased probability.
Igniting the fight once more, Hakari
throws another punch but Hajime blocks
it and completely batters the bulked
up high schooler, punching him in
the side of the head and kneeing him
in the stomach. Jumping back though,
Hakari flexes while screaming "renewal", leading
the potty emergency riichi scenario to occur.
During this Riichi scenario, if the Denji
wannabe who’s stuck on a hypothetical
train headed to Yoyogi-Uehara doesn't have a
bathroom accident or more specifically as it
implies here doesn't have any accident at all,
will results in a jackpot riichi scenario for
Hakari. As the train flies forwards, its
shown that this fake chainsaw man named
Hiro just barely made it to his stop without,
causing Hakari to once again hit his jackpot!!!!
Standing there with his eye’s closed and just
looking like a king, Hakari suddenly opens his
eyes and screams for his music to begin once
more. Sometimes I personally wish I could make
sound effects with just my mouth like booooom
as Hakari finishes speaking his body once again
erupts with a flood of cursed energy, restarting
his invincibility and the brutal showdown.
Time to kick things up a notch here boys, so
subscribe to save my throat from the throat goat!
Standing opposite him, Hajime notes how this is
the same form that will last for 4 minutes and
11 seconds, meaning that he currently has
no restrictions on cursed energy and can
automatically activate a reversed cursed technique
id damaged. However he also notes that this time
the jackpot was an even number, meaning that if
he activates his Domain Expansion right after,
his increased probability will have ended,
meaning he won't get another jackpot again
as quickly after. So he states to himself that if
he can make it through the next 4 minutes and 11
seconds he will win.. But as his smile grows
larger, he recognizes that line of thinking
is how losers think. INSTEAD HE SCREAMSSS THAT ITS
TIME TO TURN UP THE VOLUME CAUSE THIS IS A FUNERAL
FOR THE LIVING, He releases a massive burst of
electric cursed energy, declaring that even though
he may be unkillable for the next four minutes
and eleven seconds, he will still kill him anyway.
Oooo but before we go any further, we skip
back in time to a moment 400 years ago where
Hajime was approached by Kenjaku, asking
if he had fun with his battle. Honestly
any thoughts on who’s body the brain swapping
fiends in right here? Wouldn't be surprised if
it was Noritoshi Kamo tbh, but who knows
let me know what you think down belows!
Anyways After replying that he didnt have fun
at all, wanting to fight him instead. Kenjaku
asks for him to spare him and says he is not
fit for fighting currently, but reveals he
heard something in Michinoku about the greatest
cursed energy output ever. Coughing up blood,
Hajime asks Kenjaku who's the strongest sorcerer
he knows. With the latter replying that it's
Sukuna, before apologizing that it was from 600
years ago saying that he wont change his mind
though. Realizing he wont get to fulfil his
own wishes, Hajime responds that if that is
the case he will entertain what Kenjaku has
to say so that he can fight Sukuna himself.
Back in the battle, the fight between Kashimo and
Hakari intensifies as they both chase each other
at high speeds around the port. As Hajime starts
to get away, Hakari launches another fat punch
that connects with a shipping container sending
it straight towards the ancient sorcerer. Seeing
it coming in time, Hajime responds with his own
brutal punch flinging the container straight back
at the approaching student. With them both
being on opposite sides of the container,
they both exchange a multitude of powerful
blows on each side of the metal box,
completely deforming and destroying it. However
as Hakari breaks through, ready to throw a massive
punch, Kashimo dodges by jumping up off the
ground before he manages to blow off half of
Hakari’s face with the shipping containers
door, exposing his face muscles and jaw.
With the fight slowing for a moment, Hajime
deduces that cursed energy comes from the guy,
but he has to use his head to direct
the flow of reverse cursed technique.
So no matter how powerful his
reversed cursed technique is,
it certainly can’t be strong enough
to regenerate his head. Therefore,
Kashimo plans to use his lightning to target
his head and completely split it open.
Following this Hajime sends his
lightning directly at Hakari,
connecting with his head. Yet... This is not
just a normal human, this is HAKARI KINJI,
and man just simply blows all of the energy
from the attack straight out of his noise as
it destroys his face, allowing him to regenerate
as he breaks. Realizing that he almost died there,
Hakari being as cool as ever laughs it off and
with only 8 seconds remaining on his jackpot,
shoots in, deciding to use even
more brute force in his punches now.
After taking a plethora of punches to the face,
chin and body Hajime darts back realizing that
Hakari is getting even faster as the fight
continues. Getting straight back in his face
though and with only a few seconds remaining,
Hakari who’s completely unkillable decides to
cut loose and totally beat down on his
opponent, elbowing him hard in the gut.
Yet surprisingly this turns out to be exactly what
Kashimo wanted, and as he smiles he retrieves a
massive streak of electrical feedback using his
staff pierced in the ground at some distance. This
streak of instantaneous lightning pierces through
the left side of Hakari’s torso on its way to
Hajime, before completely and utterly blowing
it to pieces mortally wounding the student.
Just then the theme song ends, marking the end of
Hakari’s “unkillable” period with Hajime stating
that its finally over... However; to the perplexed
surprise of the ancient sorcerer, HAKARI IS NOT
DONE, Instead moving his hands into placement
and opening his domain again once more...
Sadly its shown though, that Hakari is just
making a desperate attempt at casting his domain
when all he’ll get are faster spins not increased
probability. Hakari keeps trying to spin faster
even if the probability is 1/239. Immediately
Hajime catches on, as the rules are implanted
in his brain and once again Hakari somehow like
the dude is a complete deeemon gains an unexpected
jackpot due to some kind of increased hidden
probability allowing him to roll an even number.
Therefore, he is again unkillable for the next 4
minutes 11 seconds. Breathing a sigh of relief,
Hakari states that he’s impressed with
Kashimo as he’s never faced death his
much in one day. But now thanks to some
manga otaku, he’s got a BIG MANGA BRAIN
and asks Hajime if he also likes manga with
the latter stating he doesn't. (Cant forgive
him for that one there boys, we all about
the manga love and support around here fr)
Annnyways, getting the battle
underway Hakari flips things
up a notch figuratively and literally
as he changes his domains polarities,
making down up and up switch before also
shifting the barriers coordinates over the sea.
As Hajime falls back towards the sea, he
states that because his cursed energy is
like electricity it wont stop discharging
until its fully depleted. He has one of 2
options in the coming water tussle, either
he can release his cursed energy until its
all gone or shut it off until he’s able
to return to land. (this goes back to his
amazing control over cursed energy that panda
mentioned at the beginning of the battle)
However, to avoid falling into the water, Kashimo
stands on the cursed spirits that burst out of
the ocean in an attempt to devour him. On the
other hand, Hakari who’s got his manga brain
fully rolling absolutely pummels a massive
cursed spirit as it bursts out of the ocean,
before shooting across at high speed towards
Hajime and sending him flying into the ocean
below with a fat kick. Then floating
above him on some fat flying fish looking
ass cursed spirit he watches as Hajime slowly
begins to burn away all of his cursed energy.
However, Kashimo is smarter than
this. He recalls that there are
two ways to end a reversed cursed energy
user. One, by blowing up their brains;
two, by using toxins. Therefore, he uses
electrolysis on the seawater to produce
a chlorine gas that completely takes Hakari
by surprise as he floats above. Sadly Hakari
loses his grip and ends up falling into the
sea due to the toxic effect of chlorine gas.
Its explained that unlike simple body
regeneration, addressing a toxin in ones
blood requires insane skill as well as a higher
level of reverse cursed techniques. Sinking down
through the ocean, Hajime notes that he
doesn't seem able to detoxify fast enough
causing the round to end and allowing
Hakari’s immortality shield to fade.
As he states that this has been fun,
Hakari like just before dispels the
excess cursed energy right out
of his freaking noise and throws
a vicious punch straight into the face of
Hajime taking him completely by surprise.
With the two floating back, it turns out that
the legend so jujutsu tech targeted the toxins
in his body and removed them unconsciously via
his automatic reversed cursed energy. With only
5 seconds left in his jackpot, Hakari realizes
casting his domain again after this one ends will
be dangerous due to the electricity coursing
through the water and the steadily increasing
temperature of the ocean. He ponders going up
to the surface but is like nah stuff it dude,
instead ima just beat this dudes ass and proceeds
to throw a fat left hook to his opponents face.
Kashimo though battered and bruised but still
excited to continue, dives forth grabbing ahold
of Hakari’s arm, before instantly releasing a
massive blast of electrified cursed energy in an
attempt to destroy Hakari’s entire arm and prevent
him from being able casting his domain again.
Back above the ocean’s surface as all of the
water falls down, we find a cute baby Panda
who’s changed his form wandering around
as he comes across Hakari’s severed hand.
As the previously lively battle now
comes to a seemingly abrupt end,
we see Kashimo plop out of the sea
after the steam blast completely out
of cursed energy. However, right when he
is about to consider himself the winner,
Hakari emerges from the sea with one
arm and punches him back to reality.
Its explained that during the
previous attack Hajime released,
before the electricity could
travel all the way through
the sea water to Hakari, it resulted in
a massive thermal explosion of hot steam.
Laying on the ground completely exhausted,
Hajime asks how he isnt ripped to pieces.
Hakari explains that he knew what his
opponent was upto and purposefully sacrificed
his left arm through a binding vow so that the
cursed energy that usually protected it
instead protected the rest of his body.
Hearing this Kashimo finally tells his enemy to
end his life. However, Hakari offers him a deal
instead as he personally doesn't see this as a
win. Hakari also brings up how Kashimo technically
didnt use his technique to which the ancient one
explains that he is saving his cursed technique
to use on Sukuna as it is a single-use one and
all Kashimo wants is to fight Sukuna. Therefore,
Kashimo agrees to side with Hakari in exchange
for a future duel with the king of curses.
Rolling onto the scene and seeing the two
hanging out, Panda is quite shocked after
hearing that Hajime is now on their side because
he wants to have a future bout with Sukuna. Hakari
discards Panda’s concern by casually asserting
that a Kouhai has to obey his Senpai’s wish,
before randomly leaving the small Panda with the
ancient sorcerer to go in search of someone else.
This is also where the announcement of a new
rule being added to the game is made. The rule
is that any player can now give as many points
as they want to another player allowing Hajime
to send his points over when needed. Its
actually crazy how all these battles are
happening simultaneously, like I love how Gege
has given us this one rule as almost a point we
can refer back in relation to other peoples
fights in other colonies. Its not a date like
it was in shibuya its just a rule letting us know
that everything that happened in the first Tokyo
Colony with Yuji v Higuruma happened in unison
with other fights in other colonies. Anyways
Shooting back over to by the ferris wheel we
find that Charles has been chilling out after
his defeat, after seeing Hakari rolling up he
confusedly asks what happened to his arm, with the
student stating that hell fix it later. The two
mates then bicker about their fight hilariously,
like Hakari is abusing this dude in an attempt to
get the name of his manga out of him cause hell
buy and read it hahaha. OOOO big plot twist theory
that me n No Operator where talking about, what
if Gege is actually French and shit is literally
a self insert of him. Things do weirdly line up,
anyway enough of me rambling. Big Momo cruises
in, interrupting their banter and asking if he
managed to get all the points necessary,
with Hakari confirming that he indeed did.
So their plan is to implement 4 new rules,
the first was to make points transferable
which was done. The Second is to allow the
use of 100 points to create a substitute
player so individuals can leave the game,
third is to remove the communication blocks and
then finally allow people in and out of barriers
Nishimiya states that she wants to forget
rule 3 for now in place of going to get 4
first as each colony seems to have insanely
strong players. The reason they know this
is because Maki can pass through barriers leaving
Hakari shocked that she can freely enter them. He
asks how its possible, with Momo stating that its
because she's turned into a complete MONSTER...
WELL OML, thats it for today's literally
insane arc from Gege Akutami’s Jujutsu Kaisen,
Who do you thinks gonna win when Yuji or
Sukuna does finally get to go ham against
Hajime? Shoutout to both Broken Ronin and
No Operator who hoped on this video, this
was my first collab with someone on my channel,
so let me know in the comments if you want more
stuff like that? plus don't forget to hit the
subscribe button if you are new around here,
leave a like and also check out my Patreon
if you want just support me even further. But
anyways for now its been your professional
degenerate and ill see you all in bit, bye!